madame monsieur bonsoir c'est une
victoire de seigneur pour richard
virenque gagne à luz ardiden
aucun français n'était parvenu à le
faire avant lui on va le prendre
définitivement au salut richard virenque
par l'espoir et de joie en levant
richard virenque a laissé loin derrière
lui le peloton pour s'emparer du maillot
jaune et du maillot à pois une victoire
qui désirent un ancien chez festina et à
sa grand mère un peu pour eux
aujourd'hui que l'original
j'avais des crampes de ventes ou des
forces pour eux emportés par la foule
richard viron qui a du mal à reprendre
son souffle
le maillot jaune épuisé par son effort
de la veille termine à près de dix
minutes du vainqueur
j'ai préféré monter tout doucement et
récupérer si on peut dire comme ça les
cinq six derniers kilomètres j'ai monté
mon train pour garder des forces
nouvelles pour les prochains jeux
richard virenque toujours là le français
au nord le 14 juillet ils l'emportent au
terme d'une longue chevauchée dans le
massif central et endosse le maillot de
meilleur grimpeur des victoires et au
bout du tunnel
le français s'impose au sprint c'est sa
première victoire cette année dans le
tour de france
allez y allez un ouais mais il fallait
pas avoir peur aux yeux dans le départ
de l'étape parce qu'il fallait faire
énormément d'efforts richard biron qui
son maillot à pois désormais plus qu'une
vieille habitude un record le français
ramène à paris son septième trophée de
meilleur grimpeur
c'est clair que je veux prendre
maintenant les étapes plus décontracté
je veux profiter du moment présent
si doit-on rester qu'un ce sera dimanche
le français part seul et va résister
quelle belle victoire
à